haz clic en la gráfica para trazar un
trapecio isósceles con vértices en menos
28 menos 4 -1 otro vértice en 38 y una
base de 9 unidades de longitud que sea
paralela al eje x muy bien entonces
veamos si podemos hacer esto podemos
empezar trazando y uniendo los puntos
entonces vamos con el primer punto que
sería menos 28 entonces en x es igual a
menos 2 y en que es igual a 8 sería este
punto
ahora el siguiente punto es menos cuatro
menos uno entonces en x es menos 4 y es
igual a menos 1 y puedes ver que khan
academy ya hace la conexión por nosotros
lo cual es bastante agradable de su
parte muy bien ahora vamos con el
siguiente punto que es 38 entonces 3,8
sería este punto pero pero aquí estoy
dudando porque creo que cuando yo haga
clic aquí va a conectar al punto 3,8 con
este punto y eso no es lo que quiero y
no quiero eso porque estamos
construyendo un trapecio isósceles
entonces lo que yo quiero es conectar al
38 con el menos 2,8 entonces bueno
veamos qué sucede si yo doy clic aquí
y eso pasó lo que no quería que pasara
pero bueno no pasa nada vamos a borrar
esto vamos a borrar esto porque lo que
haré primero es trazar vamos a trazar
primero este punto después este punto
después este punto y ya después veamos
cuál es el el vértice faltante del
trapecio y sociales que estamos
construyendo muy bien entonces bueno
vamos a borrar lo que hicimos y vamos a
empezar de nuevo así que todo esto va a
la basura no nos sirve
así que primero trazamos el punto 38 y
bueno espero que esto no nos estorbe
3,8 sería este punto ahora vamos a
trazar menos 28 menos 2,8 es este punto
y aquí puedes ver que se forma la parte
de arriba de nuestro trapecio isósceles
y bueno también podemos ver que nos
proporcionan la longitud de este lado
del trapecio muy bien así que la
longitud de 5 ahora vamos con este punto
menos 4 como menos uno menos cuatro coma
menos uno es este punto
y puedes ver que ahora si esto está se
está pareciendo más a un trapecio cierto
muy bien las indicaciones dicen que que
esté trapecio isósceles tiene una base
de 9 unidades de longitud que es
paralelo al eje de las equis vamos a
movernos 9 unidades a la derecha para
formar la base de 9 unidades de longitud
de nuestro trapecio y sociales que
estamos construyendo y que la base es
paralela al eje de las sextos entonces 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 unidades
ahí está el siguiente punto y por último
simplemente vamos a conectar vamos a
conectar estos dos puntos y ahí lo
tenemos muy bien
este es nuestro o trapecio y sociales y
que significa trapecio isósceles
significa que estos dos lados los que no
son ni ni la base ni la parte de arriba
sino que estos dos lados
me den lo mismo tienen la misma longitud
podemos ver que este lado es igual a
este lado y la parte de arriba tú puedes
ver que está en medio cierto así que
bueno a mí me agrada mucho este trapecio
y sociales que construimos y ahora
comprobemos nuestra respuesta
veamos si lo hicimos bien